let me welcome you to
the first session of dr sandler's
philosophy forum uh it's something that
we're trying to hold using google
hangouts on air
um this session is is not going
exactly as planned in part because uh
it's our first time actually
experimenting with this this google
hangouts on air
and i'm not sure who's able to to join
in the hangouts uh but people can in
fact comment
and ask questions by going on to the
event
feed and i see quite a few
comments already by people many of them
are pretty short
so i am going to
talk just a little bit about
why i picked socrates
uh and then i'll start addressing all
the the comments and questions that i i
see coming up
so
socrates is is one of those figures who
really
um
steered the course of of western
philosophy and he impressed his his
character and his way of life
and his modes of thinking upon
a number of different people plato you
know we think of his his most important
student but he had a number of other
people surrounding him
who he influenced and many of those
ended up founding other philosophical
schools of their own
he is actually responsible for for a
number of different
we could call them traditions in
philosophy the platonic tradition of
course the aristotelian tradition
through the platonic tradition
um
the
the uh
academic skeptic tradition which is
coming from plato's academy but much
later on um the stoics are deeply
influenced by socrates through two
different uh threads one is the
cynic thread coming from antisthenes
and another one
is coming from
um this this mergarian school that was
interested in dialectic and the guy
who's important for that is still paul
so you have all these different things
going on you also have an uh aristippus
one of the first hedonist philosophers
uh at least in the greek traditions
um
not in you know he's sort of
counter-poised to epicurus who's kind of
on his own doing his own thing
but socrates really
gets western philosophy as such rolling
there's a kind of unity
of
philosophical inquiry that comes about
because of this guy and
he he occupies a role somewhat like a
hero figure
um and you know some of the later
commentators that that we could look at
like you know nietzsche furniture he's
really an anti-hero for kierkegaard he's
you know
the best thing that that that philosophy
or a reason unaided by revelation can
pop can possibly provide us with
for for hegel he's this you know
corrosive force that gets things
moving in in the sphere of the mind so
what's really interesting about socrates
is we have a lot of different portrayals
of the guy
he himself never wrote anything down so
everything that we know
comes from other sources like plato
xenophon
aristotle to a certain extent although
he's not considered to be as reliable uh
aristophanes this comic who is a
contemporary of socrates
everything we know about this guy is
coming through these kinds of sources
and
his eye his ideas were sufficiently rich
that he managed to
lend to these different people a number
of different
portrayals a number enough material
that they could see him in in
quite different ways so the stoics
socrates looks quite different than
socrates is represented by by plato or
by xenophon let alone by aristophanes
and um
you know what was it about this guy that
that
made him
so so central to what was going on so
let me uh now look at some of the
the uh questions in the feed i'm sure
there's more stuff here
uh coming up um
wow actually quite a few
um
so let me start
with the earliest stuff because i think
that's that's the the most fair
um
psyctuter mentor says learning about
socrates way of viewing life helped me
to win two court cases this year against
the owners of the property that they
rent just thinking i am the gadfly um
well um socrates is the the founder
in a lot of respects of
and not not so much the discipline of
dialectic because what socrates was
doing was not systematic but this this
notion that by engaging in dialectic by
engaging in argument
where you're required to
maintain consistency and you can you can
use uh analogies to test that and you
can ask for definitions and then try to
see whether those definitions actually
match up not only with you know what the
person is saying at the time but with
what what else they've said or the kind
of way of life that they have
um that's that's the socratic um
approach i don't want to say method but
but approach and plato took that on um
and and you know refined it more and
then finally with somebody like
aristotle we see something much more
systematic coming about
but um even with aristotle everything is
not totally systematized there's still
this notion that there are these these
fundamental deep questions that we we
you know have to plow at and a lot of
the
lesser questions are
preparatory you might say towards um
their their practice for for being able
to to approach those sorts of things
um let me take another one uh
scrolling up a bit now
what do i think is the best
representation of socrates by by plato
or socrates other students and this is
from from christopher dunn
um
so i tend to think that that plato's
representation of socrates
is probably our best bet i do like
xenophon and i don't see in xenophon
the sort of contrast that some scholars
want to say is there um between you know
plato's socrates who is very you know
smart and and gets what's going on and
then xenophon socrates is kind of a
um
you know just a a guy who's got a few
themes and says a few you know witty
things from time to time i will say this
that in plato's dialogues socrates tends
to be the guy who gets in all the
zingers and in xenophon's dialogues like
the symposium for example there's stuff
going back and forth and back and forth
and back and forth so i think xenophon
is uh in some respects a bit more fair
to some of the other
uh the other characters who were all you
know real life people but they're being
depicted in ways that are probably a
little bit
uh fictional
um
so i tend to like to see you know where
so
the socrates of xenophon and the
socrates of plato overlap now this
brings up a big issue that i i knew was
going to come up in this discussion
called the socratic question or the
socratic problem um not the socratic
question though that would just be uh
you know socratic questioning the
socratic problem
what is actually historical in the
accounts that we have of socrates
and
most people think that aristophanes is
not the aristophanes the comic
playwright who has socrates in the cloud
is not the place to go to for this so
it's between xenophon and and plato
which one should we
give more credence to i tend to think um
if you know if we come down to the wire
it has to be it has to be plato but i
also tend to think as do a lot of
scholars many of whom you know know much
more about this than i do
that um
some of what we're getting is socrates
and some of what we're getting is is
plato after socrates sort of refining
his ideas and going further with it
and doing some other things introducing
some other themes that socrates himself
was not working with
i don't know where you can actually draw
the lines reliably
between you know early dialogues middle
dialogues late dialogues there's a lot
of discussion about that and from my
research into it what i've seen is that
it's very similar to what goes on in in
other quests for historicity as well um
you know with respect to the the quest
for the historical jesus schweitzer you
know said after the quest had been going
on for a while you have all these
critics and they're saying here's what's
what's actually historical here's what's
historical this is the other stuff
that's not um and he said they're like
they're all like people looking down a
well and seeing a reflection at the
bottom and you know whose reflection it
turns out to be theirs
so
you know
there's always some sort of interpretive
framework that's being brought whenever
we want to say here's here's the
historical socrates and then here's what
plato
added to it
and the trouble is where are we getting
this historical framework largely from
plato's texts
so
you know there's there's a circularity
there to that so you know long story
short i tend to think that we should we
should rely on on plato
we do get
some
references to what socrates thought or
did
from the other students
uh
through the traditions that they they
engendered so if we're talking about the
the cynic tradition unfortunately
antisthenes all the things that he's
written we've lost those so we don't
know what he actually wrote
but that flowed into the um the stoics
and
zeno the the first stoic was influenced
greatly by crates a uh
cynic and by stilpo a magarian who's
kind of a
strange figure himself
and
zeno is sort of like a let's go back to
the sources kind of guy because
according to diogenes liertes
he reads xenophon's stuff on socrates
and he says where can i find a guy like
this
and they they direct him go go buy those
cynics because they're of that sort and
so there must have been a lot of oral
traditions passed down
among these schools but what we've got
is very piecemeal uh it's not enough to
actually like it's not enough to
make a real figure the way that plato
has or xenophon has
in talking about socrates so that's a
that's a good question um
i want to take what i can remember of
the question that zero she flies uh put
together which had to do uh with some
some pretty high level stuff
he was asking about um
the simplicity of the soul versus the
parts of the soul
and
in some texts like the phaedo we have
socrates saying that the soul is simple
that it's one single thing
and then in the um
in the the republic of course there's
that famous tri-partition of the soul
there's the
uh you know the logical
rational uh part which is sometimes you
know identified with the mind noose
um there are the appetites the epithelia
and then there's this thumbos in between
what we call the passionate or spirited
or the part of the soul that gets angry
is actually how plato
discusses it
the part in which we feel courage
now
are these parts in the sense of being
separable from each other are they parts
analogously to organs in the body
or should we think of them as being
something different
so
if if we look ahead to aristotle
aristotle discusses something very
similar to this um
in the on the soul
he says um
you can you can divide the soul up you
know among the parts however you like
but you're not dividing something into
like actual separate parts it doesn't
really
work that way and i think that there's
something like that going on
the the notion of them being
parts as analogous to physical things
misleads us
so i don't know if that's helpful or not
but that that's how i tend to think
about about that
all right let me move on
okay so mark smith has a question
several questions here
when socrates says that the only thing
he knows is that he knows nothing
considering plato's theory of knowledge
could you say that socrates would claim
that what he knows at best is that he
holds true beliefs
how does he know it is a true belief and
not a false one and how does he
differentiate truly from knowledge can
you have knowledge of your own ignorance
or only a true belief that you are
ignorant so these are some really
uh
big questions and
i'm gonna give
answers that are not going into the very
depths about them but sort of skimming
the surface this is a real tension
in plato's works
um
and it's also reflected in a historical
tension and it in order to see this you
would actually want to read cicero where
cicero is having you would actually want
to read cicero's day academica on the
academics
where he's talking about what happened
to to the the
the students you know much later
students of the platonic school when
they became skeptics and they would
trace themselves back to socrates
and they would say well look this guy
said that he didn't he didn't know
anything
and that
he only knew that he didn't know
so we're really going to be like like
him we're going to be you know faithful
to his spirit
um
this is a this is a so this is a tension
that you see not only in plato's works
but also playing itself out in the very
history of philosophy in the the
platonic tradition
um
i tend to look at it this way i think
that socrates some of the time when he's
saying he doesn't know something he is
by the time he's being ironic and that
he's engaged in what kierkegaard would
call indirect discourse
um that he's he's saying things that are
on one sense
they're on one level true and on another
level false and the idea is to try to
provoke
in the the listener the hear the
interlocutor some sort of shock you know
like mino talks about you know the shock
that he gets from socrates in a dialogue
where socrates is talking about this
very this very issue about the
difference between knowledge and true
belief and whether he has knowledge or
not
i think that that socrates
he has more knowledge than he he admits
to
and this is a controversial view not not
everybody holds that view on socrates
um
i i don't think
that the
this is a side note i don't think that
the platonic
way of treating knowledge
actually is a very successful one
not just because it makes appeal to
forms or stuff like that forms are kind
of an interesting idea
i think it's what it does is it sets the
bar for what counts as knowledge
so high
that it's very difficult to meet that
and anything in between is just you know
true or false opinion
and you know how do you differentiate
one true opinion from another it's
closer to what's actually real the
person who has knowledge can give a full
rational account of what it is
that they are they are knowing they are
committed to now ontologically it means
that they're actually participating in
the form of whatever it is that they're
they're knowing at the time and that
gets really tricky to figure out what
the hell what is going on with that so
let's let's actually put that aside
let's brush that under the rug um
does socrates have just true belief
in
whether he has knowledge or true belief
or in about his lack of
of knowledge of some things
that's a pretty interesting question
isn't it
because if he
if he actually has knowledge there's
this self-referentiality if he if he
knows anything
if he knows that he doesn't know
then he knows something right and then
it would seem that he's caught in a
contradiction
um
that's about as far as i'm going to push
this this particular question there's a
lot there's a lot of interesting issues
there that could be could be delved into
more so i apologize for kind of skipping
from that
to other things um
but i do want to get to some of the
other questions and comments and make up
for some of the time that we lost
monkeying around with the
the beginning
okay so kevin l asks why do you think
that plato decides to leave socrates out
of the sofas
and
why why is soccer you could ask this
question in a couple other ways you
could say why isn't socrates always the
main character um because there's a few
other dialogues that come to mind too
like you know think about the
permanentes
where socrates is this young guy
and first of all plato actually gives
you some arguments against
his own theory of the forms in that art
in that that dialogue doesn't he and
then he has parmenides go on this long
long discussion about about things it's
very different than a dialogue say like
the gorgius where the old man uh you
know comes in socrates actually goes to
somebody else's house and proves the old
man gorgeous who's like you know this
major public figure
uh
wrong about stuff and then then gorgeous
uh disciple
polis steps up and socrates best him and
finally the guy who owns the house
says enough is enough socrates we're
going to hash this out and calculus
loses to to socrates as well why doesn't
plato have socrates always be
the winner
well
um
one theory is is that that
that's a sign that in these dialogues
these later dialogues we're dealing with
plato's own thought and and not really
um socrates
thought that that's one way in which we
can we can make the the dividing lines
between them
um
i i have to admit i i don't really know
i i don't i i tend to think
that
um
at best when we get to those sort of
questions we're engaged in guesswork
and that
maybe maybe plato got tired of
using socrates as a foil or a mouthpiece
all the time and wanted to sort of come
into his own
um
it's interesting though i mean
think about the symposium
there
socrates is a really important character
right and and uh
who does
who does the talking about socrates and
the praising them to the sky it's not
socrates himself and it's not even the
the the dialogue
transmitter it's it's alcibiades the
the nut job coming in at the very end
drunk and then you know talking about
how great socrates is
um but who does socrates
refer everything to to this teacher
diotima this wise woman who may or may
not have existed
um
and there you've got you know plato
putting in socrates mouth
socrates putting somebody else's
words uh in in uh
in in his own mouth um
that's pretty confusing to say that
uh so i i don't really have a great
answer for the question of why in
particular dialogue socrates is not a a
interlocutor or an important character
or the one who
who
wins or speaks for for plato but it's a
good question
um mark smith there's another question
uh considering socrates comparatively
causal practical and personal approach
to philosophy what could be said about
the opinion he would hold of the more
institutional
academic structures of the academy
plato's academy and hellenistic schools
would he disapprove of it
well that's that's an interesting
question i i have to admit i have not
thought uh much about that um
here's here's what my first thoughts are
so socrates sees philosophy
as the care of the soul
as
doing what you need to do in order to
acquire self-knowledge in order to find
out where the sources of knowledge are
to work upon your
your own self uh so that you you not
only know yourself but can be in control
of of your your desires and and all
these you know things that go
go wrong uh in in your in your life
would he have been against
um
the more institutional academic
structures of the academy and the
hellenistic schools
um
he doesn't seem like he would have
insisted like like plato that first you
have to learn geometry and then you can
then you can do
other things
um
but i don't think that you would have
been just against
institutionalizing or systematizing
things per se
the the proof of whether that's that's a
successful strategy
would be what kind of lives it turns out
so he would want to look at
what kind of people are being turned out
by these these schools
you know it'd be a really interesting
question if socrates
could have met aristotle how would that
have gone you know because we know he
knew plato right
um but but what about aristotle or zeno
the founder of the stoic school
or what is socrates that actually met
epictetus who idolized him by the way
epictetus would be a great great sort of
counterfoil to this
epictetus talks about um
his own school the stoics and he says
yeah you get these people who can you
know like they read clay anthies
who wrote a lot of books you know and
and they learn all this stuff but then
they can't actually practically apply
any of it and really what you ought to
be studying first is how to how to
unscrew up your life
and then start worrying about all this
other more
abstruse you know logical systematic
stuff first like get you know figure out
who you are what your desires are
whether you can actually control them or
not then let's work on this this other
stuff and socrates does seem to be a bit
more like like epictetus in that in that
uh that that way
um there is a real tendency and you can
see this um
not just like an old comedy with
aristophanes
but especially with with somebody like
um
lucian of sam sosta right
who's a uh
a satirist
he writes a lot of interesting things
about what philosophers are like in
their day-to-day life
and
in their schools
and at dinner parties where a lot of
them act like complete you know complete
fools and and don't practice what they
preach at all you know um and at the
same time are like trying to praise
their own school for how great an
approach to life it is socrates would
say the proof is in
the kind of people that the school
produces
um
so you know it it on a last note with
that so you have plato and he found the
academy
uh and then you know aristotle's gonna
have the lyceum
antisthenes found the cynic school but
it's not much of a school he writes some
things uh and he he does you know the
things that he does
and people will follow him um but he he
really puts a lot of uh
you know obstacles in their way to
follow him and the cynic way is much
less systematic than say the platonic
way
or um you know the aristotelian way
let alone the stoic way later on
all right so let me
look at some other
questions i'm really enjoying
this
um
so zero she flies has
a
question you mean analogous to the
trinity and i'm not sure
what the context for that one is
um perhaps it has to do with this
tri-partition to the soul oh yeah that
way that would make sense
so analogous to the trinity no i don't
mean analogous to the trinity because
that that's a much more complex thing
there you're they're that's that's a
hard one to wrap your head around where
you have
three
distinct
things and they're all at the same time
the same thing
um
but they exist in their distinction from
each other and with the the true you
know traditional christian notion of
trinity god is holy father holy son holy
holy spirit it's not like you know
there's one third over here and one
third over here and one third over here
with plato's conception of the soul
when he is talking uh in in the republic
and in
like the fado no the phaedra sorry and
in um some of the other dialogues where
he's touching on the notion of the the
soul being divided into parts
he goes so far as to say
that um
the appetites are the largest part
and that these other parts are smaller
but but more important
so there is
some sense that
the mind is not the entirety of the soul
the appetites are not the entirety of
the soul the most is not the entirety of
the soul so it wouldn't it wouldn't be
analogous to that
um
oh now here's here's an interesting
question
um
kevin l asks are you familiar with
kierkegaard's repetition if so how do
you think that an ancient philosopher
might react to something like
recollecting forward
regardless i know that socrates was
extremely influential to kierkegaard but
i am not sure exactly what influence
influenced him would you be able to
speak that influence so two different
questions there
how would an ancient philosopher react
to something like uh recollecting
forward
um it would it would throw him for for
quite a
loop and here we're touching on
something
that um
i think would would
this is going to be very controversial
and probably not make a ton of sense to
some of the the people listening to this
one of the things that i work on
and one of the reasons i'm attracted to
somebody like kierkegaard is these
discussions about christian philosophy
and and how philosophy
uh ends up doing something different and
still remaining philosophy within a sort
of christian
uh not just intellectual perspective but
a way of life and it does
does christianity sort of open up
things that that previous
philosophers perhaps suspected were were
there
but just didn't make uh weren't able to
to to access and this is what the early
christian philosophers by the way like
you know
um
loctancias and justin martyr and all the
way to people like augustine this is the
way they actually talk about it in in
some of the the cases
so
would socrates be like totally at a loss
posed with somebody like kierkegaard's
uh position
i don't think he'd be totally at a loss
but it would take a kind of um
shifting on on his part
to
to adapt himself to it
and i think that some ancient
philosophers would not do very well at
all
with something like that because their
dogmatic frameworks
would just simply you know rule that out
and i think they would prefer their
framework to
to um to that
now
what what influenced um
kierkegaard about socrates
that's a good question
so kierkegaard thinks of socrates
as the
uh you know the teacher par excellence
as as showing us
what it is
that
human reason can do he says that you
know you have later philosophers but
they haven't actually progressed beyond
socrates in this ex
to this extent
and what socrates does is um presumes
and shows us
that at least with respect to certain
kinds of truth the truth is within us
and it just requires us to work at it
and work at it to find
uh that truth to purify it to refine it
to bring it to light and then to to
apply it
so that that's something that
kierkegaard thinks is very important
kierkegaard by the way you know with
these
distinguishing say the ecstatic and the
ethical and the religious the religious
is something higher than these other
stages but that's not to say these are
nothing kierkegaard spends a lot of time
talking about these
these other things because they are very
important as well
um another thing that that influenced uh
kierkegaard is this notion of irony
and what is going on in in socratic
irony is it just him sort of you know
downplaying himself is it is it a way of
um
you know closing questions off or or
poking fun at his audience or is he like
trying to say two things at the same
time
one
uh you know on the surface and then
another thing that that requires a bit
more effort and reflection and and sort
of
bringing one's own personal perspective
into it to make sense out of it um those
are those are some of the things that
influenced uh
uh kierkegaard uh pretty pretty heavily
and and i think
arguably still you know keeps showing up
throughout his his works
um kevin owl says that other people
should
should ask other questions so i'm
actually going to skip over the question
about uh deodorant's speech in the
symposium and the fillet because i don't
actually have that much to say about it
um okay so neo0 asks is it true socrates
learned from a woman named deotema is
there much known about this woman or is
it just a rumor to sway socratic themes
we don't know
we don't we don't really know
much about this this uh this person
whether she
existed historically or whether she um
is just sort of something that's that's
made up to
you know to pin some some doctrines on
it is very interesting that that plato
would would
place all of these things in the mouth
of
of a wise woman
um i'm not sure what just a rumor to
sway socratic themes maybe you know
maybe by that you mean something like a
a mouthpiece or a character that can say
that sort of thing
um the fates have warned asks both
aristippus antisthanes and plato were
all students of socrates but they had
very clashing beliefs aristippus being a
hedonist
antisthanes and plato being virtue
ethicist plato arguing against hedonism
and the dialogue gorgeous why do you
think this is the case
well that's that that's that issue of
socrates influencing people in different
ways and different people taking from
from him
the the things that they wanted
we we know
that aristippus and antisthanes
also had personality clashes from time
to time but they they did tend to
also come from their way of life and
their philosophical commitments
um
i don't know if you can say that
antisthenes was a virtue ethicist in the
same way that we talk about virtue
ethicists like plato
and aristotle and uh
you know augustine and thomas aquinas
and people like that
uh he's he's you know much closer to the
stoics
he's the founder of the the cynics
school
and
it would be really nice if we if we had
more than just glosses in diogenes
laertes about antisthenes
or even if we had some of the books that
diogenes laertes mentions
antisthenes wrote
dialogues and wrote wrote treatises and
we don't have any of that stuff so we
don't we don't know that much about it
we know that he was pretty
uncompromising
and
that he you know found this school that
has a you know fairly coherent way of
approaching things we know about
aristippus's uh doctrines as well
um
aristippus and and uh anticipates are
kind of like you know at antipodes with
each other
um plato you might say is kind of in the
middle
um i think that's probably all i can say
about about that
now here's a question about more
contemporary issues
do you think the idea this is from
christopher dunn do you think the idea
of the socratic method is lacking due to
this the society that we're growing up
in today
and do you think we should emphasize the
socratic method starting in grade school
so let's be really clear about what
people generally mean by the socratic
method because i think a lot of people
throw that term around sort of like
people throwing on the term critical
thinking
and it means different things in
different people's hands
a lot of times people will talk about
the socratic method as just asking
leading questions and never ever like
you know saying that i believe this or
i'm going to take this stand
if that really is supposed to be the
socratic method it's not very much like
the socrates who we actually see in the
dialogues it's like a caricature of of
socrates
the socratic method as socrates is
practicing it requires some
confrontation
and saying hey but wait a second you
said this over here how does that match
up with this over here and also making
proposals could it be perhaps like this
it's not a pure just sit back and you
know just let the the students kind of
figure it out themselves
um
sort of thing and it requires some
training to do well
uh people get very frustrated i can tell
you from experience having tried to do
it when i was uh
early on in my career
and then you know the students just
wouldn't
wouldn't engage and you'd be like come
on you know ask the right questions or
give you know give some responses that i
can do something with
and uh
you have to learn how to overcome those
kind of frustrations socrates is very
good at guiding people but
then again he's doing it in plato's
dialogues
where maybe we're only getting the best
hits of socrates maybe there were days
where socrates couldn't get a rise out
of his audience and couldn't get them to
to you know rub two thoughts together
and make smoke as a friend of mine used
to say
um in any case so let's say we actually
have good practitioners who are you know
trained who are fairly patient
um who have some good will towards the
people that they're they're engaging
with
um should that be something that um we
emphasize starting in grade school i
think you know in a lot of cases we do
um i see a lot of teachers who who
practice that sort of thing but should
it be something that we do a bit more
you know more institutionally with more
emphasis on it
it certainly couldn't hurt i mean it's
it's doing something different than say
teaching to the test
or beginning with lesson plans all the
time you know
um
one of the most dulcifying experiences
of my life is trying to write lesson
plans um
so yeah i think it could be it could be
a good thing but it would require some
some practice and it would require some
uh
eventually i think what you want to do
is get the students to start doing that
themselves
you know dialectics
is something that you do with other
people but you also do with yourself
that's part of the process of getting to
know yourself
and caring for the soul in the socratic
senses thinking things through on one's
own not not just
having somebody else now may you know
should we
expect grade school kids to do that i
maybe not maybe that's uh
expecting a little bit too much
from them
um
oh
interesting so zero she flies has how
about socrates versus epicurus
so epicurus is an interesting guy
because he's outside of the box so to
speak everybody else
all these other great
traditions and philosophy in the
hellenistic world
socrates is somehow
got his finger in that pie you know
metaphorically speaking
epicurus is something coming in from the
outside and independent of that and
that's reflected
even in the very way that epicurus
writes
um
according to to diagenes laertes who's a
big fan of epicurus
epicurus wrote in in a way that was very
different than every everybody else and
he didn't worry about um
engaging
other other philosophers too much
he's got his own sort of progression um
he's using democritus as
physical theory democritus is a
roughly a contemporary of
of uh
socrates i think you know
i mean these guys are not exactly
overlapping but but they're they're
they're close
and
he's he's got his own orientation
towards things he is doing something
kind of similar to what some of the
later thinkers are going to do and his
school is doing something similar
but they can stand aloof
the other schools tend to uh share
things back and forth more the
epicureans tend to be over on their own
their own side
um
all right so let me move on christopher
dunn says here's a quote from heraclitus
one of them one of his very famous
quotes we must recognize that war is
common and strife is justice and all
things happen according to strife and
necessity
what do you think that socrates would
think about this quote
well uh again if if
layer taste is to be believed socrates
couldn't make heads or tails of
heraclitus
now you know plato obviously understood
some some heraclitus because he
he brings up heraclitus and heraclitus's
followers in a couple dialogues
including the symposium where he he has
a little discussion of one of the
passages not this passage
but a different one
socrates
you know
one of the things that aristotle credits
socrates with paying attention to is
the role that motives play what we call
final causality
and how these the how these things
actually
function in getting human beings to do
things so he talks you know in the
the phaedo for for example he says you
know if if um
if i was just a product of of my my body
then these bones would have gotten the
hell out of here a long time ago when
they had the opportunity is going to be
read back in the the credo uh instead
i'm choosing to to stay here
um you know would would socrates be
willing to get behind all things happen
according to strife and necessity i
don't think so
um
this is you know this is a good place
actually where like nietzsche and and
socrates
um
are you know at antipodes this war is
common and strife is justice that could
actually be in the genealogy of morals
and nietzsche saw socrates along with
euripides as representing
uh the pinnacle of a new approach in in
humanity this isn't
not the genealogy morals isn't the birth
of tragedy a very early work
he sees them as a a
you know apex and you had a decline at
the same time
um by by getting away from this notion
that
all we really have is force operating
and the will to power you know imposing
itself on on lesser things and making
them conform
and that justice comes out of that this
nietzschean way of looking at it
he thinks that that that hellenistic
culture kind of lost its way with
somebody like socrates
so uh kevin owl uh
advises reading scotus on the university
of being for more info on the trinity
discussion yeah you read scotus you
could read anselm who i'm a scholar on
who writes on the trinity as well or
read aquinas or you know there's a
number of different people i'm not sure
why we would want to read scotus but
uh
it certainly doesn't hurt to read him
i'm not i'm not a big one on the
university of being
um
so
mark smith
asks another question something that
often strikes me as the similarities
between themes and ideas raised by
socrates and plato
and those of eastern philosophies and
mythologies arising at the time notably
buddhism
the emphasis on virtuous living
supremacy of the material being escaping
the cycle of reincarnation
was there any exchange between western
and eastern thinkers even if indirectly
or was an aspect of that period in
history that led people to those type of
ideas
um
neither really i would say it's both of
those are kind of uh those are popular
ways of looking at things but they're
they're kind of oversimplified the the
second one is this you know so-called
axial age
theory
which um
once you start looking at it doesn't
really work you know people want this is
very popular in the early 20th century
to say well you know
um confucius in china and you know the
buddha and the maha and
in
india
and zoe astor and you know the greek
philosophers
and some of the the prophets they're all
like doing all this stuff at the same
time so there must be like some you know
something going on with humanity but
then when you actually start looking at
the history of it
turns out it doesn't work like that
because zoe aster actually gets
backdated to about 12 1200 uh bc
and you know the profits are sort of all
over the map and it just
it's hard to buy the more that you look
into it
that there was some sort of you know
radical transformation of humanity going
on
all across the board
um was there exchange between western
and eastern thinkers there was exchange
between western and eastern thinkers
to a small degree
and not back then
but much more later
in the time of alexander the great on
where all of these um
all these are being brought together in
one major
i mean we we could translate it as
economy and you know oyconomia um a
a uh
big empire you know uh which broke apart
into parts but but culturally
with alexander's time and now we're
talking about you know roughly
contemporary with aristotle
um you do have eastern and western
thinkers coming into to you know
discussion with each other
um
well eastern western and western because
you have zostrian you know thinkers as
well there
um
in central asia
you know the greeks are bringing their
influence uh west and and the
other stuff is flowing east
but that's after plato's time
plato is is seems to be getting some of
his stuff
uh in part from the pythagoreans
and
some people want to say well they must
have had some conflict i don't know you
know
this was
this notion of reincarnation there were
there were some people who had those
ideas
um in in greek thought at that time um
i mean pedicles for example
um
emphasis on virtuous living well you can
find that sort of thing really really
widespread and so you don't have to look
to to buddhism
in particular for that
and their conceptions of virtuous living
are quite different i mean there is a
very ascetic
there's a very ascetic point of view to
socrates and plato you know especially
if you're reading the fado the uh the
body is the coffin of the soul
um but it's not it's not
totally illusory it's not ultimately a
void
um
and
okay supremacy of immaterial being for
plato
i suppose yeah but in in you know
traditional buddhist thought
even
things that we would call soul are are
really going to be um
unreal as well and that's not the case
for for plato um
i exist as a soul that that that's in a
body that's that's the sort of platonic
view on it
there's probably more connections
between uh that you could note between
buddhist thought and then later gnostic
thought which which is incorporating
some platonic elements
let me move on i don't want to
spend too much time on that so the fates
have warned rights which philosophers of
the modern era do you think socrates
would have had the most issues with
would have the most issues with today
so the modern era i'm going to like push
this forward so in the modern era we're
actually talking about what we call the
late modern era
because maybe that's what's intended i
think socrates if he were to show up and
he were to see what gets taught as
philosophy and a lot of philosophy
departments would uh
be quite disheartened and would say i
don't know what the hell these people
are doing but it sure as hell doesn't
seem to be like philosophy
a lot of analytic philosophy and
continental philosophy would would
strike him as sophistry
uh just you know quibbling with words
you know it's funny
i'm probably gonna alienate some people
by saying this but
if you look i'm a historian of
philosophy so you know i see connections
between these sort of things if you look
at early modern philosophy and their
criticisms of scholasticism which was
pretty moribund by by the you know the
1400s 1500s 1600s
what are their biggest criticisms hobbs
is a great great example of this he says
that the scholastics jangle with words
and ignore
things
they're great at drawing distinctions
and
you know producing arguments but they're
they're crap and actually figuring out
anything that we want to know about
i see something like that happening when
i engage with a lot of my analytic
philosophical um
trained or still practitioned you know
practitioner uh peers who i like as
persons
but you know
you you you read a lot of their stuff
and you're like wow not only is this
mind numbing but i don't see any point
to it
and it seems like you so you you talked
about this person who nobody actually
reads or knows and how their distinction
actually could have made could have been
made better and should have incorporated
line p in this and you know socrates
would say
caring for the soul not really
acquiring knowledge about anything not
really and i think a lot a lot of that
would also happen with continental
philosophy where
to to that sort of thing
people add a lot of you know terminology
that that oftentimes just
made up on the spot you know i mean to
lose makes up words foucault makes up
words
and they don't always serve you know
great purposes so
you know
now here's a good question would what
would socrates say to people like me
these historians of philosophy
who um
you know are are saying well we really
need to to not just you know look at the
arguments or what we can turn you know
what critical thing we can turn plato to
we want to actually read plato for its
own sake and try to make sense out of it
as a whole and you know look at it as an
approach and situate it within within
its own time but not just
confine it to that i'm not even sure
that he would call you know what what
we're doing a philosophy he might say
that we're
we're
more librarians
so
um
yeah
let me answer
some others
um
psyctucker tutor mentor critical
thinking
critical reflex reflective thinking and
writing definitely ways to go okay i
agree
about that
um
christopher dunn notes uh nishita kataro
was a famous japanese philosopher that
mixed up the ideas of socrates plato and
buddhism i'll have to uh i'll have to
take your word for that i haven't i
haven't read him
um
there's a lot of gaps in my in my
reading unfortunately
zero she flies writes what is socrates
view of evil
is it only the absence of knowledge or
virtue as opposed to metaphysical force
uh
referred to in the amino the uh
uh hallucinating mysteries and and that
sort of thing okay so those are those
are purgative mysteries
that are um or rituals think of it as
like a ritual and a a
organization that are supposed to
bring about some sort of um
salvation experience
by by rooting one of what's bad in
oneself and we don't know that much
about them unfortunately but what is
socrates view of evil is it only the
absence of knowledge or virtue
ultimately yes that is in fact
that is in fact socrates and it appears
to be plato's point of view
socrates very famously doesn't think
that we can be a critic that is to know
the good and and choose
willingly not to do the good so he
differs from aristotle or augustine on
on those points
and he thinks ultimately um the evil
that we do
that can be you know deeply rooted in
our very souls
is a
function of not knowing what the good
for us actually is what what really is
good misidentifying
lesser goods as
as the good like say money or prestige
or or fame
that that's pretty consistent there now
what's the metaphysical status of it
evil
um
for for plato
well i mean think about it this way
ultimately the only thing that's truly
really real
would be things like the forms and
souls and the gods whatever the hell
they are according to plato because that
that's kind of changing up a bit
um
and
material things
are
at best sort of you know deficient
copies
of those and you know like the knowledge
that we have inside of our i shouldn't
put my head because that's very physical
knowledge we have in our soul
is
just a copy of the thing that we we
actually know the form
so there's really no place in that
ontology for evil to
to exist as something that that has you
know you might call it ontological
density or or depth or weight
it's going to be a function of
you know i think what augustine later is
going to call
privation
um
aristotle by the way has a lot of
discussions of privation in the
metaphysics
about how that
works let me take uh
let's see what else we have here for
for questions
um
oh here's an interesting one and i am
going to butcher your name because it's
it's a
difficult one and has some diacritical
marks that i'm not sure how to pronounce
so
uh lena's
uh mikuta
vicious could that could that possibly
be it
uh since philosophy is the mother of all
sciences and we now have many fields of
them do you think philosophy should
branch into each of these get more
focused
what i'm saying is we have gathered a
lot of knowledge about the world since
the age of plato shouldn't we have the
cornerstone of philosophy be modern
rather than ancient
well you're really two different kinds
of questions there
so
should philosophy branch into
the different disciplines i'm not going
to call them sciences
because that would leave some out
should philosophy branch into each of
those and get more focused yes and it
does so you have philosophy of
mathematics you have philosophy of
science you know
and if you're if you're doing biology
and you're doing it at a high level and
you're reflecting about the discipline
and about the status the ontological
status of what you're you're doing and
asking ethical questions you are doing
some philosophy anyway
um what i'm so what i that's that's a
pretty easy one to answer
um
like heidegger points out and like a lot
of other people pointed out too
the disciplines are not particularly
good at actually
doing two things one is not seeing the
whole world in terms of their discipline
and also they're not that good at
reflecting on their their own practices
and what what's going on with that
because they tend to impose sort of
reflexively their own their own uh
their own filter through which they're
they're bringing things in
um so we've gathered a lot of knowledge
about the world since the age of plato
shouldn't we have the cornerstone of
philosophy be modern rather than ancient
so maybe we begin with hobbes and
descartes and gescendi rather than plato
well the one doesn't follow from the
other
and there's a couple reasons why this is
a big conversation um so i'm going to
actually just give you a few reasons
where a lot of other ones could be could
be given and explored
the issues that are that are put on the
table in ancient philosophy are still
live issues today
and there's good reasons why and if you
want to understand
why those are that maybe you find that
in some ancient philosophy like read
aristotle topics book one
there are some
questions that we can't successfully
close off
there are some modern ways of looking at
this think about gabriel marcel and his
discussion of mystery versus problem
uh which can make sense of that as well
but
it's a mistake to think that because
we've acquired more knowledge in the
disciplines
that therefore
the
asking the bigger questions which the
disciplines tend to do you know not such
a great job at even even articulating
that somehow that's done better in
modern philosophy than in ancient
philosophy or even in medieval
philosophy i think we should study them
all
uh an intro to philosophy class should
introduce you to to some of the big
thinkers throughout the ages i i have to
admit that because of the 15 week format
i tend to shortchange the the moderns
compared to the ancients and medievals
um
but since there's so many people short
changing the ancients and medievals in
favor of the moderns maybe that's that's
a good thing but
you
you will find just as much depth just as
much worth
making sense out of and just as much
adaptability to the world that we live
in in aristotle as you will in descartes
or in plato's as compared to kant
so
i don't think that that we should have
the cornerstone of philosophy be modern
rather than ancient
i think that would actually reinforce
some bad tendencies we've already got
going on
um
so kevin l writes i assume you won't get
to any questions below since below here
since we're running out of time
i hope that you will do this again
sometime on other topics thanks so much
we are running out of time but i also
you know it's my
my hangout so i get to make it go on as
long as
as i'd like i do have other things i
have to to get to
you know anything is better than grading
but this is the time of year that i'm
supposed to be
spending a lot of time on finishing up
the grades which have to be posted uh
fairly soon
but i'm going to see if i can get
through the rest
and i will be doing this again sometime
on other topics i'm not sure exactly
when
and i i i would really like to actually
have this function the way it's supposed
to which is not just me talking at the
screen but actually getting to hear some
some viewers talking um but
alas
google hangouts on air has not done uh
exactly what it should
um
there are
there's quite a few
more i'm gonna like read and scroll down
so ziroshi flies says tom tomism could
be a future topic would be interesting
yeah thomas aquinas is a guy alike
um
i will uh
eventually do do some discussion about
that tomism is one of those things where
you gotta ask who's tomism
because there's a lot of different
varieties of it
neo0
this is the last one i'm going to to
address that i'm going to read the ones
down unrelated are you going to put this
session on youtube
yes supposedly the way this is supposed
to work
is
this goes to a youtube video it's
supposed to be live streaming and i
assume you're actually able to see what
i'm saying here and i'm not just you
know
haven't just been talking to myself for
for an hour um
but it's supposed to turn into a video
and then i'll put that on on
on youtube
um so let me scroll down now anthony
haynes hey dr sandler i'm not sure if
you read the contemporary literature but
broadly what do you think the future of
tomism is
um that's a good question and and that
would that would be a good one to answer
more in a session on tomism i think the
the the prospects for tomism right now
are about what they they have been for
the last couple decades
um it is it's gone from being sort of
it never really was the official
philosophy of the catholic church that
was always something that thomas would
say
and uh people who i think didn't
understand
thomas but actually liked you know
thomas would say
um but there's a whole story there a lot
of a lot of catholic philosophers are
quite uninterested in thomas aquinas but
but
um in compensation
a lot of protestant philosophers uh have
become very interested in thomas aquinas
and i see actually see that as a good
thing i don't like the
i don't like when a philosopher becomes
sectarian
you know i mean i don't want to think
that in order to study jonathan edwards
i have to
become a presbyterian or a
congregationalist
to be taken seriously
so i i think that's you know
tomism it's you know it's one approach
that's out there there are some places
where you can do it
um it's certainly
uh
not in the the mainstream i don't think
that analytic tomism is really
uh that great of a fit but you know that
that's my my personal view on that
um
apologists rights apart from the
concepts of heaven and hell
do we find any similarities between
platonic philosophy of socrates and the
teachings of jesus christ thank you
well
by the teachings of jesus christ you
mean just the gospels
uh yeah there's i mean there's there's
some you know uh
shouldn't be
shouldn't be bad to people um
you know you should try to forgive when
possible socrates seems to be pretty big
on that although he's got somewhat
different justification for that
there's this emphasis on actually being
consistent you could think about
parables
like uh the one where
where uh and this is in luke and i don't
remember
exactly where but the guy um
is is you know he's got a big debt
and his uh
his creditor says hey i need the money
now you better pay me now or i'm you're
going to the debtor jail and that's sort
of like almost a death sentence back
then
so
you know he finally he gets sort of
remittance from it and then he goes and
he
starts throttling some other guy who
owes him in a lesser amount and then the
the first guy's like what what the hell
is wrong with you
you know you saw me do this forgive you
why why don't you do it to him so that
emphasis on consistency in in moral
behavior i think is is important
but that's not something exclusive to
socrates and and christianity
i will say this
in early christian thinkers platonism is
viewed as like the philosophy that
almost got it right and i think that's
in part because of
the the uh the notion of
you know asceticism and the soul
um
the the the survival of the soul
and if you if you take
the republic or the the symposium the
the the form that is beyond everything
and helps create everything or sustain
it in being
um it's not personal in plato but that
that's god for for christian thinkers
also jewish neoplatonus and muslim
neoplatonist as well
so yeah i think there's there's there's
some similarities
uh mark smith writes what about pure ado
do you think his emphasis on philosophy
is a way of life which i think socrates
would agree with should be emphasized
more in contemporary philos
philosophical courses
yeah you know haddo is one of those
people who i i i like but he's one of
those people where when people bring
them up i'm like uh yeah we already knew
about that why
why did we have to hear this when all it
takes is to read epictetus or to like
closely read plato
and you're gonna realize that it's a way
of life
um it be emphasized more yeah uh and if
you know citing pirado is a way to do
that i guess that's a good thing
i tend to think that if you go back to
the texts and you think it through
the life as a philosopher cannot be a
mere academic academician's life
um
i mean if you're if you're doing ancient
philosophy and you're doing medieval
philosophy and you have any love for the
people that you're reading
you're already sort of trying out their
ideas and seeing if they have any sort
of relevance in in your own life
and i try to stress that to my my
students because i i teach i don't teach
any philosophy majors right now
and throughout my career i have not
taught
philosophy majors for the most part i've
taught these service classes for you
know core curriculum
uh so i've had to orient my my teaching
and my own you know presentation of
things to people who
if they're going to take this stuff
seriously it better have some
application to their their own life
um okay so last question i'm going to
take
adam young i think philosophy should
always be looking ahead to future ethic
to eventual future ethical dilemmas
caused by increased integration with
technology
that's an interesting thing to say um
it's hard to figure out what the
what the new dilemmas are going to be um
you know
more case jorge louis borges said
uh he might have been taking this from
somebody else's in one of his essays
he's talking about jules verne and h.g
wells
and he says that they're both seen as
these you know important you know
science fiction or what we would now
call you know sort of speculative
fiction authors
and there's a fundamental difference
between them
jules verne would take what he saw going
on at the time and sort of extrapolate
from that to what would likely be the
case or what could be the case
so he's going
within the realm of probability and just
sort of pushing things further on right
so a submarine that would go you know
all the way around the world or things
like that and that came to pass
h.g wells is working with a very
different kind of imagination where he
is working in the realm of possibility
rather than probability
and thinking about
could there be a time machine and what
would that be like
now the reason why i bring this up in in
relation to this this uh this comment
is because um
to figure out what the future ethical
dilemmas are going to be or the future
ethical issues however we want to
whatever term we want to use for this
problematic situations
there's there's both of those going on
at the same time and it's a hell of a
lot easier to like look ahead on on
likely probability paths right and say
well you know if we keep up with this
medicating kids we're going to run into
this this issue here you know
um but to figure out what the real
you know out and left field issues are
going to be that's practically
impossible
sometimes we just have to like you know
wait until they show up and then we're
like oh crap now we've got a big problem
and we better figure out you know what
we're going to do about this
um
there are going to be you know
more issues arising because of the
increased integration with technology so
let me put a plug in here for some of
the videos i've been doing recently
these philoso geek music philosophy
reflections on the technosphere
what i see going on is exactly what
you're talking about increased
integration with technology our our very
way of life i mean think about what
we're doing right here i'm talking with
people all over the world
through this tiny little dot on my on my
laptop
um and we have a you know real space
here but it's being put into this this
entire virtual
network and i'm able to read what you're
saying we're able to make sense of
things we're sharing things back and
forth this is going to be saved
somewhere i'm not exactly sure where you
know even virtually i have no idea where
it's going to be saved physically
but all this this stuff is going on i
set aside you know certain time in my
day for this to take place so it slices
up our time
um there was a reminder of it on my on
my phone
we are living in a world that is
increasingly
uh
integrated is is becoming part of what
we're call what i like to call this
technosphere so
there are a lot of
ethical issues that arise because of it
you know um
i bring up in class for example with my
students things like um
is it okay to put a you know a mean
facebook comment on somebody's post and
you know what are we doing there we're
talking about
things that are technology upon
technology upon technology and and yet
we treat them as if they're they're
perfectly natural and part of our life
um so i think that that's a good thing
to point out
so um
this strikes me as a a good place to
bring the broadcast to a close i thank
all of you for your questions for your
attention
for bearing with the
the slow start because of trying to
figure out how exactly google hangouts
on air work which turn out to be
something quite different than regular
google hangouts
and hopefully this has been captured and
will be turned into a video so
um have a good weekend
and uh
yeah that's that's pretty much it